hey guys now we all want to look decent
and presentable when we go to school
work or a date or even to a friend's
house and yet a lot of men don't look
their best because they make grooming
mistakes that give people the wrong
impression of them so in this video I'm
gonna talk about the 8 biggest grooming
mistakes men make and how to prevent
let's just very quick if your first time
here on my channel I'm Daniel and
welcome to my channel if you haven't
subscribed yet then please consider it
and also clip that notification about so
won't miss any of the next videos now
let's start with the first grooming
mistake
a lot of men leave their nails too long
and day if you don't keep your nails
short and clean will give people the
impression that you're not very hygienic
and that's not what you want so keep it
short and please how short well you
should at least leave a little wide at
the top of your nails with a nail
separates from your skin and the same
thing goes for your toenails sometimes
when I see guys feet those toenails
[Music]
leaving your ear and nose hair I mean
some guys get more hair than others but
if it's visible and creeps out of those
holes it looks terrible
you should always trim it it should not
be visible now some of you might still
be young and you'll say I don't have it
well just wait you're gonna get older
and you might get it
not caring enough about your hair you
know we need to take the subway and then
you are next to somebody and you see
their hair is very very greasy and dirty
or they have dandruff and you can see it
and also here on the shoulders that
should never happen to you you gotta
wash your hair at least two to three
times a week and then if you have
dandruff don't just hope that it goes
away you got a deal with it
get some anti dandruff shampoo and get
rid of it a lots of good options for you
in a video description down below that
you can check out
[Music]
smelly armpits the other day somebody
said you know I don't care so much about
putting on deodorant because I want
people to like me for who I am well yes
that's fine if you want people to like
you for who you are but they're not
gonna like your bad odor think about
this how will somebody get to know you
if they can't even come close to you
because you stink no you got to put some
deodorant or antiperspirant on after
every shower and please shower every
single day
another thing I want to mention here is
some guys they got very long armpit hair
and it makes the antiperspirant or
deodorant less effective and it also
causes bigger stains on your clothes so
if you're one of those guys with very
long or bushy underarm hair then you've
got to trim it you don't have to shave
everything off but just keep it trimmed
[Music]
another grooming mistake is that some
men used too much product too much
cologne and too much hair product your
Cologne might smell really really good
and you want people to smell it that's
fine
but if you put on too much it will
definitely drive them away from you
just two sprays on your neck and maybe
one on your arm is fine and then when it
comes to hair products never overdo it
I've also talked about this in a
previous video but it is really bad for
your hair and it looks terrible and some
guys still use the old spiky hair gel
style and they use almost a whole bottle
but today it's better to use pomade or
wax or even just a pre styler like sea
salt spray you want to go for that clean
and natural look where your hair looks
styled but you can't see the product
[Music]
untrimmed facial hair oh there's a lot
of guys who look better if they grow
their beard but not if you just grow it
and you don't keep it style if you don't
trim it if you have a beard is the same
as the hair on your head you need to
keep it styled and trimmed now there are
many cool beard styles out there that
you can try and even if you're just
going for the stubble style you need to
trim it so that it looks like a style
and not like you are just lazy to shave
it if it grows longer shave off your
neck hair and the hair on your
cheekbones
now I had to shave my beard for seven
reason but I'm gonna grow it out again
and I like it when my beard is shorter
under my ears and it goes longer towards
my chin shaving against the grain of
your beard for some of you who like the
shaved look is always a bad idea to
shave against the grain of your beard
now of course there are some guys who
are blessed with a tough skin and they
can shave against the drain of their
beard and it can help them with a very
very clean shave look but for others
like myself if we shave against the
grain
we'll definitely get ingrown hairs razor
bumps and irritation so if you're one of
those guys who always wonder why do I
always get bumps after I shave that's
one of the reasons for a better result
you can get another razor like the
quality single blade razor for an
electric shaver and of course I'll add
some good options for you in a video
description below
another grooming mistake is not washing
your face before bed after bed and after
your workout you've got to remember your
face represents you and throughout the
day it will get dead on and it will get
into your pores so you got to clean it
so that you always look sharp and fresh
and even better start the easy basic
skincare routine that will give your
skin what it needs to look its best
again I'll add some good options for in
the video description that you can check
out and do some research on
alright guys now let me leave you with
this reminder even if you have the best
clothing the best shoes the best
accessories none of it matters if you
have a bad all right guys I'll see you
in the next video Cheers